I mean how is this feeling for you you
direct this project it's getting all
this acclaim are you kind of on a high
right now sure it's nice I mean it's
always nice when people like something
that you've done and you know no matter
what it is you always put your heart and
soul into it so when it's well-received
after doing all the work it's a great
feeling and I'm happy for everybody
that's involved with it your daughter
was in a little bit right yes she's in
episode six of the show and that was
really fun the first time that she got
to do something and you know she was
kind to me on set
did she want a whole trailer
she was very good her deal was easy to
make but it was really fun to work with
her you want to kind of impart any
advice to her and show her what that's
like is she heading into more Hollywood
you know honestly I just wanted it to be
a good experience for her I want her to
have fun because it's actually kind of
strange when you come in if your dad's
the director because all eyes are on you
and there's a lot of pressure because
you're not anonymous so I just wanted it
to be fun and positive and she had a
great time I think she left wanting to
do it more and wanting to keep exploring
her art so I'm a big fan of hers well
you know I mean you're such a person to
learn from you've done everything we're
celebrating this year a big anniversary
of friends and we wondered what your
favorite memory was from guest-starring
on that show it was so much fun I
remember there's one scene where I think
I'm yelling at a little chick or
something the angry guy and I just
remember everybody sort of crack we all
cracked up because it was getting so
ridiculous and I remember thinking oh
this is fun we're all this is just the
most ridiculous thing I've ever done
you've now been on SML well we see you
back on SML again you know it depends it
depends if the news keeps on putting a
character into the into the into the
limelight I mean it seems like he's not
going away it's I usually get the call
the night before so you know as they're
figuring it out but I'll be there if I
get the call from Lauren
[Music]